so I met her outside of the cafeteria oh
okay look this one
she is British and you guys know how
much I love the Brits you mean her yeah
that that's that's her already I'll
settle down settle down guys we have a
new addition to the troop
she'll be joining anybody that might be
needing a partner if anybody's going to
take her in June she does have a partner
you were just talking about that right
Jim is perfect you'll be doing a scene
from the themed play called I fell in
love with an English girl by Richard
Beckett you'll love it you'll be great
oh great
[Music]
okay so I'll see you tonight for hustle
sounds good
yeah you are so in you get to hang out
with her outside class oh my god I think
my puke
come on come on look look just play it
cool this is what you have to do to get
it first things first
do your research what does she like
where does she go
these things are important post some
cute selfies on Instagram so she knows
how adorable you are then make sure you
have a ton of candles lit girls love
games wears no fancy perfume - I have
something cooking girls love food I
don't think food is gender specific okay
whatever
as long as you can make a recipe and not
[ __ ] it up that will impress her and
she'll come inside and say they're so
cute and this house smells so good are
those brownies I love brownies then say
something related to her interest like
have you seen the new Wes Anderson film
what he does with colors is just
astounding
oh yeah and do a hair flip why just do
it and then you grab her face and kiss
her no girl would ever fall for that ah
work for me once right twice okay well
how about we try when you eat the door
you're already on the phone and you say
sorry Saul ready president Jenna waters
I have to cancel our plans tonight
because I have important appointment why
Jenna because she's attractive and
popular but the point is to look
important hang up the phone after
talking to Jenna or Obama or whoever and
then offer her fancy cheese girls love
cheese I'm lactose intolerant okay
most girls love fancy cheese you run a
scene and then afterward you get choked
up and say sorry I just haven't loved a
scene as much as I played Eponine in
lame is on Broadway maybe something a
little more realistic okay fine I'm
trying to get you laid here how about
sorry I just haven't loved the scene as
much as I started chorus member number
two in late May is at my high school and
that's when you pull out your guitar and
play this song you wrote for her she'll
swim and then you grab her face and kiss
her I know that's a lot of pressure to
put on my guitar skills okay how about
this she comes to the door and you
answer it as your cool calm collected so
he runs through the scene and say
something nice like really good at this
very natural oh my god good actually can
get that out with a straight face okay I
mean I was being genuine I'm trying to
pay you a compliment yeah you're right
I'm sorry I'm just I'm really bad at
taking compliments me too I mean there's
this one time when this guy told me that
he liked my glasses and I shouted you
are and then I ran away real quick
that's pretty funny it is now kind of
traumatic at the time sorry um it's
getting late we should probably finish
this thing
oh I thought we did it says that I
across to you and then I say I have
something to tell you yeah but then he
grabbed my face and he kissed me what
does a kiss at the end of the scene
there is this isn't the transfer student
isn't
yeah okay welcome I heard that she got
in trouble cuz she tried to rob a bank
she's come to America to escape the law